Aubervilliers près de Paris
Fabienne Rochon 31 ans est assistante
sociale
elle fait ce métier depuis 8 ans et
chaque matin dans le bus elle se demande
comment elle va tenir le coup
une importante pression au niveau du
service on a beaucoup de rendez-vous on
a taux de rendez-vous assez élevé avec
des situations vraiment très très
difficiles de personnes et nous on est
face à ça au quotidien et il y a des
jours où la pression est très très forte
et ça ça nous use la pression sur ses
épaules c'est de trouver tous les jours
des réponses aux situations de précarité
les plus difficiles
au centre social d'Aubervilliers 21
assistantes sociales comme elle
travaille à temps plein
en général Fabien vous vous sentez
comment avant de commencer la journée
un peu Sisyphe je me dis j'arriverai
jamais à rouler mon caillou au bout de
la montagne
il retombera avant voilà quoi donc c'est
vrai que là on prépare les dossiers pour
tous les rendez-vous de la matinée et
oh là là tout ça
chaque jour est un nouveau marathon
premier rendez-vous ce matin monsieur
tuile il vient la voir depuis deux ans
avec moins de 800 euros par mois il a de
gros soucis d'argent
j'aurais pas payé
vous les avez prévenu que vous pouviez
pas payer non
213 euros monsieur twils je ne trouverai
pas 213 €. d'accord
rapidement payer quelque chose pour
éviter la coupure
j'avais mes enfants qui sont venus à la
maison je leur ai fait à manger ça fait
quelques années que je faisais pas mon
anniversaire faut bien que je vive
s'il ne paie pas sa facture monsieur
tuiles risque qu'une coupure partielle
d'électricité
Fabienne va demander une aide au Secours
catholique et un délai de paiement AEDF
jusqu'à juin qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à ceux qui disent c'est de l'assistanat
je leur demande de vivre avec le budget
qu'on a que les gens on est content
l'excès qui s'est permis c'est de fêter
son anniversaire avec ses enfants il a
fait à manger à ses enfants je peux pas
dire à Monsieur vous avez fêté votre
anniversaire vous avez invité votre
famille
fallait pas le faire ça je peux pas je
veux dire à quoi ça sert de se maintenir
dans une vie sociale au niveau des
critères c'est-à-dire logement budget
enfin tout ça si à côté on vit pas
Fabienne suis régulièrement une centaine
de personnes comme Monsieur tuile
facture impayée surendettement
malnutrition logement insalubre elle
doit faire face à toutes les situations
restez toujours à l'écoute
[Musique]
les gens qu'elle reçoit attendent
beaucoup d'elle plus qu'elle ne peut
donner ce père de famille au RMI vit
dans un logement insalubre depuis trois
ans Fabienne n'arrive pas à le reloger
dans un HLM malheureusement quand on a
le Jérémy ça ne joue pas en votre faveur
pour reloger les familles elle ne peut
faire que des recommandations ce sont
les organismes HLM qui décident
l'aberration du système c'est que pour
avoir le droit au logement social qui
est pas vraiment pour les personnes avec
des plus petites ressources
et ben non on prend les selles qui ont
des ressources et c'est hallucinant
c'est vraiment le problème maintenant on
fait rentrer en jeu qu'une donnée
économique qu'on fait pas entrer en jeu
des données sociales et pourtant ça
s'appelle du logement social normalement
[Musique]
ça s'appelle du logement social que le
nom
l'aide au logement et ses contradictions
c'est le principal problème auquel elle
est confrontée vous habitez tout seul
[Musique]
pour votre fils il habite avec vous
ce retraité vit dans l'un des quartiers
les plus vétustes d'Aubervilliers
sont deux pièces et tout juste habitable
les services d'hygiène ont dû installer
des vérins car le plafond menaçait de
s'écrouler étant donné la situation le
propriétaire ne lui demande plus de
loyer
les flanchez comment ça vous voyez vous
voyez ici
c'est pareil vous voyez ici ça commence
à courir bien sûr
ça va tomber les
c'est pas c'est pas solide tout ça
monsieur Bara est d'origine marocaine il
a travaillé 35 ans en France comme
électricien ici il y a la chambre
oui donc là vous vivez en fait avec
votre fils je suis toujours avec mon
fils à 72 ans il souffre de diabète et
d'insuffisance rénale il aurait aimé
profiter de sa retraite dans un logement
plus décent
il y a deux ans que je fais la demande
pour un logement je n'ai pas je ne l'ai
pas
monsieur Barat aurait pourtant de quoi
payé le loyer d'un HLM mais Fabienne n'a
rien à lui proposer mais je peux pas
vous dire ce que je peux faire par
rapport au logement sachant que Monsieur
J'ai pas reçu pas c'est pas miraculeux
ce que je peux faire hein d'accord les
personnes dont la situation est très
difficile au niveau du logement des
assistants sociales elles peuvent faire
un dossier qui s'appelle le FSL
relogement prioritaire fond de
solidarité logement au logement
prioritaire d'accord ce dossier une fois
qu'il va être si je peux le faire et qui
va être validé va pas vous donner
forcément le logement d'accord c'est
pour essayer d'appuyer un peu votre
demande ok c'est pas un dossier qui
aboutit forcément à tous les coups par
un logement ok légalement monsieur
ghmara aurait le droit d'être relogé de
façon prioritaire mais il manque
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
logements sociaux en France bonne
journée à vous aussi
prioritaire ça dépend il y en a qui au
bout de six mois obtiennent un logement
par ce biais là et d'autres on
renouvelle puisqu'on renouvelle tous les
ans ça peut durer combien de temps un
logement prioritaire
il y a à peu près 2 ans 2 ans et demi
on a toujours pas obtenu quoi que ce
soit
Fabienne a souvent un sentiment
d'impuissance dans son travail être à
l'écoute sans pouvoir apporter de
solutions c'est souvent difficile à
vivre
il y a des jours où ça nous ça nous
atteint bon quand on a on enchaîne toute
une permanence donc c'est vraiment
enchaîner un peu enfin c'est un peu de
travail à la chaîne des fois ou donc on
essaye quand même d'être extrêmement
à l'écoute à disponible pour les gens au
bout d'un moment oui ça peut ça peut
nous attendre il suffit que nous on soit
un peu fatigué qu'on est nos problèmes
personnels ça résonne pas bien du coup
ça nous ça nous met un peu ça nous
attend
6 heures du matin près de Béthune dans
le Pas-de-Calais
Stéphane Coquerel croit qu'il peut
changer la vie
sa famille est encore endormie lui se
lève toujours très tôt pour aller
travailler depuis 4 ans il est conseillé
financier dans une banque associative
l'a dit pour 1500 euros par mois
son travail financer les projets de
création d'entreprise de ceux qui sont
exclus du système bancaire car ils sont
trop pauvres
une société qui ne sait plus inclure les
gens c'est plus qu'exclure ou c'est
chacun pour soi et donc c'est aussi une
volonté de faire aussi un peu pour les
autres
Stéphane Coquerel s'est engagé à la dit
juste après ses études de sciences
politiques un événement familial a
révélé sa vocation
en fait mon père est prêtre donc suite
au décès de ma mère il a quitté le monde
de l'entreprise il était il était Vice
Président de Chambre de commerce il
était à la tête de 36 salariés
il a quitté quitté tout ce monde des
affaires pour pour se consacrer aux
autres ça m'a donné envie aussi de me
consacrer aux autres j'en ai retrouvé la
foi et ça m'a donné envie d'essayer de
m'engager aussi
avant de financer les candidats à la
création d'entreprise il examine leurs
projets attentivement ce matin il va
revoir pour la seconde fois un RMIste
qui veut lancer une entreprise de
soudure SOS soudure l'homme a déjà
trouvé un petit local dans ce garage
Stéphane veut s’assurer de sa capacité à
mener son projet jusqu'au bout il y a un
soudeur dans le coin
Mokhtar Belhassen à 41 ans cette
entreprise c'est un peu sa dernière
chance
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez monsieur
comment vous avez trouvé ça
il a perdu son travail de soudeur il y a
10 ans pour des raisons de santé et
depuis il a enchaîné les boulots
précaires
ça c'est une petite réalisation que
j'avais fait pour ma fille quand elle
faisait les volumes à l'école en
primaire je lui ai fait un cube un
triangle et un parallélogramme rectangle
et ça c'est 6 pièces de métal qui sont
soudées chacune donc ah oui donnons j'ai
mis un petit
quart d'heure
du beau travail mais il en faut plus
pour convaincre Stéphane Coquerel
monsieur Belhassen multiplie les
arguments pour montrer que son projet va
réussir vous vous êtes chez vous vous
avez être cliquant ce que vous allez
faire vous le souhaite à la poubelle
vous avez pas une idée d'aller le
réparer mais si vous avez un service qui
vient vous dire moi je suis chez vous
SOS soudure voilà bonne pub prenez les
enfants aujourd'hui ils ont des
trottinettes vous avez vu les
trottinettes électriques à 400 euros à
350 euros quand ça casse qu'est-ce qui
répare YouTube a besoin de 4000 euros
pour acheter du matériel de soudure
aucune banque n'a voulu lui prêter cet
argent
les banques si on n'a pas d'argent
c'est-à-dire si on a un petit on a
aucune garantie on n'a pas de maison en
gars à mettre en garantie on n'a pas
quelque chose qu'on a maintenant garanti
à part soi-même ou on motive ou ils ont
beaucoup de bonnes volonté mais ils sont
pas là pour vous donner de l'argent en
quelque sorte ils sont là pour gagner de
l'argent la dynamique autour du projet
on la voit ici on est dans on voyait le
propriétaire qui laisse le local la
complémentarité le projet le potentiel
les outils la passion qu'il a de son
métier ça je crois que un banquier sera
pas le voir mais parce qu'il aura pas le
temps lui il va plutôt voir passer les
gens son bureau il va dire oui non oui
non oui non si jamais c'est un gros
investissement il y a une service étude
qui va avoir éventuellement le risque
mais je dirais que ce soit des petits
près comme ça c'est pour eux par
rentable de penser enfin de passer le
temps qu'on passe c'est pour ça Stéphane
Coquerel repart convaincu à son tour
désormais de convaincre le comité de
crédit de son association qui décide de
financer les projets
ma voiture ok bon merci
donc je sais pas votre projet est
continue à me plaire d'accord donc ce
que je fais j'attends que vous
m'appeliez merci
rendez-vous et pris dans une semaine
Marseille parmi les combattants de la
pauvreté il y a de vrais bagarreurs dans
cette ruelle près du vieux port le
cabinet de Maître Candon
[Musique]
à 37 ans ancien chanteur de rock Benoît
cordon est un avocat à part dans la
profession
[Musique]
j'arrive j'arrive
oui maître Bagnoli oui bonjour Benoît
Candon avocat concernant notre depuis 7
ans qu'il exerce il a fait de la défense
des pauvres son domaine de prédilection
attendez
pourquoi vous défendez les plus démunis
qu'est-ce qui vous motive une certaine
idée de la justice en fait de du droit
comme étant quelque chose qui doit être
qui qui quelque chose de bon qui qui
fait qui fait progresser les gens et qui
qui est nécessaire qui est
à l'inverse un dégoût de l'injustice en
fait ça m'a toujours frappé de voir des
gens qui se font punir qui se font
flageller alors qu'ils sont pour rien
enfin depuis tout petit c'est un truc
qui m'a toujours frappé alors bon
peut-être que je règle mes comptes avec
mon passé
gare de Montpellier
là où Fabienne l'assistante sociale
tente de poser des pansements
Benoît l'avocat est dans un combat sans
concession sur le terrain du droit
cet après-midi il a rendez-vous avec des
gens du voyage monsieur Jory et son
épouse
le maire de la commune où ils sont
installés veut les expulser depuis un an
il leur a coupé l'électricité
j'estime que
quel que soit l'issue juridique de leur
problème fondamental qui est ce qu'ils
ont le droit de stationner là ou pas
entre temps ils doivent vivre de façon
décente c'est-à-dire il doit avoir
l'électricité vivre sans électricité au
21e siècle ça devient complètement
aberrant quoi surtout quand on a des
enfants qui doivent faire leurs devoirs
aller à l'école quand il faut se faire
fonctionner un frigo endetté on part
toujours de l'hiver pour le chauffage
mais il y a le frigo l'été il y a
énormément de choses quoi c'est une
question de décence en fait moi ce que
je plaide le droit à une vie descente
c'est quand même bizarre donc nous
sommes quand même j'ai ma carte
d'identité je suis de devant ça
monter avec clôturé je suis chez moi je
vais être tranquille je demande rien les
jury habitent sur la commune de
Lansargues près de Montpellier
ils vivent sur ce terrain dans des
caravanes avec leurs trois enfants
ils ne l'ont pas payé cher seulement 30
000 francs mais le problème c'est qu'il
n'est pas constructible la mairie
s'appuie là-dessus pour refuser le
raccordement électrique
[Musique]
il y a juste un fusible à remettre donc
c'est un fusil qui doit se trouver là
dedans je pense et le terrain il n'y a
pas loin c'est juste à côté
monsieur Jory est artisançon les revenus
de la famille tournent autour de 900
euros par mois avec les allocations
familiales
l'absence d'électricité leur rend la vie
difficile mais voilà vous avez tout là
vous avez le lavabo
on a pas le droit
électricité
sans électricité on peut pas faire
marche à la douche
depuis le mois de septembre on passe un
calvaire
faire chauffer l'eau tout le monde a
atteint là pour faire chauffer son eau
pour se laver
on se lave dans une bassine comme ça
depuis qu'on est installé ici on n'a pas
pris de douche on se lave la tête dans
une bassine les enfants font pareil on
se lave comme ça que on a tout le temps
pris des douches les douches c'est allé
en tant que ça existe dans les caravanes
et là depuis le mois de septembre qu'on
est rentré que le maire nous a coupé
l'électricité on a plus droit à tous ces
besoins quotidiens qu'on a droit on a
droit à une vie descente quand même
leur combat se joue aujourd'hui au
tribunal administratif de Montpellier
vous entend pas du tout nous sommes avec
Maître Kango individuel il est bien là
en chair et en os donc je me sens dans
une bonne cause mais bon peut-être que
l'avocat adverse va vous dire va être
persuadé du contraire elles sont bon
droit et lui aussi
pourra partir en croisade contre ces
gens qui qui imitent notre territoire
quoi le maire de Lansargues s'est
déplacé en personne mais il ne veut pas
s'exprimer
[Musique]
son avocat lui défend une idée simple
pas d'électricité sur un terrain non
constructible
je pense que il y a un minimum de règles
qui existent pour l'utilisation des sols
aussi il faut s'étonner de ce que les
caravanes ne soient pas raccordées au
réseau il faut s'étonner aussi qu'on ne
puisse pas construire des maisons
partout c'est exactement le même
problème un arrêt du Conseil d'État a
déclaré haut et fort que le fait qu'un
terrain soit un constructible n'empêche
pas qu'il soit raccordé n'empêche pas
nécessairement qu'il soit raccordé qui a
raison bon apparemment peut-être moi
parce que je suis du côté du pauvre mais
enfin une phiné on sait pas
argument contre argument c'est dans la
salle d'audience que tout va se décider
hors caméra
les plaidoiries vont durer une heure
à la fin de l'audience pour mettre canon
ce n'est pas tout à fait terminé
ma soupe
c'est-à-dire
la maigre pitance de l'État pour tout ce
trouble on doit justifier que les gens
qui ont défend ont pas suffisamment
d'argent pour se payer leur avocat voilà
et là vous êtes payé combien pour cette
audience c'est moins 2000 francs c'est
120 euros 130 euros c'est une misère
c'est pas très rentable de défendre les
personnes qui ont pas de revenus bah non
mais
Dieu merci on gagne souvent donc quand
on gagne la partie perdante est
condamnée à rembourser les frais
d'avocat et à une hauteur correcte cette
fois-ci Benoît cordon perdra
la famille Jory n'aura pas droit à
l'électricité
la cité des Bosquets à Montfermeil en
Seine-Saint-Denis il est 8h le collège
Jean Jaurès classé en zone d'éducation
prioritaire est encore vide
Laurence Ribaucourt habite tout près
elle est assistante sociale au collège
depuis 14 ans pour 1700 euros par mois
son combat à elle il est dans les
petites choses qu'elle peut apporter aux
familles en difficulté
à 37 ans divorcé sans enfant elle
consacre l'essentiel de son temps à son
travail c'est clair que mon boulot il
fait autant partie de ma vie que le
reste c'est clair que et mon travail et
ma première passion je pense que je suis
contente de petites choses c'est ça
aussi je suis contente de rencontres je
suis contente de sourire je rencontre
des changes parce que sinon
effectivement si on regarde vraiment au
fond des choses si on me demande si
j'améliore la vie des gens j'ai pas de
réponse j'en sais rien
elle n'en sait rien mais elle y croit
quand même un peu malgré 14 ans
d'ancienneté chez elle pas la moindre
trace d'usure
l'école et le moyen qu'elle a choisi
pour aider les enfants de la cité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime l'école profondément je pense que
l'école c'est un lieu de vie très
importante et c'est vraiment un endroit
où on peut faire plein plein de choses
et on construit l'être humain et c'est
une grande chance pour nous qu'on a
parce que c'est là qu'on peut encore
agir sur la vie future des gens donc
c'est bien c'est bien il y a plein
d'espoir c'est super
ce matin dans le collège elle doit
recevoir un élève de 4e qui pose de gros
soucis à ses professeurs
depuis quelques mois il sèche les cours
presque un jour sur deux
Moussa risque de s'enfoncer dans l'échec
scolaire à un moment crucial pour son
orientation les professeurs ont alerté
Laurence elle veut intervenir avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard
parce que tu as été quand même beaucoup
absent du collège ouais comment ça se
fait que ça c'est pas bien passé à la
fin des fois j'ai pas trop envie de me
lever je suis fatigué j'ai pas envie de
venir à l'école
Laurence sait que l'absentéisme des
enfants est souvent lié à des problèmes
familiaux elle a appris récemment que la
maman de Moussa avait perdu son travail
en ce moment
tu penses que c'est à cause de ça
peut-être du mal à t'accrocher à l'école
des questions mais aussi des messages
clairs à lui faire passer je cache pas
que tu fais partie des élèves les plus
absentéistes et le collège il va faire
son travail c'est-à-dire que là si nous
on n'essayait pas d'aider les élèves il
devrait signaler la situation et après
ça peut avoir des conséquences sur les
allocations familiales etc etc donc ça
peut encore aggraver encore plus la
situation on en est pas là pour faire
sortir Moussa de son inertie Laurence
joue sur la fermeté mais elle veut
surtout lui redonner le goût de l'école
extérieur qui pétudiant par exemple
viennent un petit peu t'aider nous deux
fois par semaine pour pour un peu
reprendre les cours avec toi c'est une
association pour aider les élèves
Laurence travaille avec une association
qui donne des cours de soutien scolaire
gratuitement
bon je sais que tu as au fond de ton
cœur tu as un petit peu envie de t'en
sortir quand même ouais
mais on va pas te lâcher
tu sais ça on te lâchera pas au moins
sur la présence à l'école parce que
c'est transservice ok bon tu réfléchis à
tout ça
parviendra-t-il à considérer l'école
comme un moyen de s'en sortir
socialement son entretien avec Laurence
suffira-t-il à le remobiliser elle veut
se convaincre que c'est possible
il y a pas forcément de fatalité sociale
il y en a peut-être une il faut essayer
d'en réchapper quoi voilà donc et que
l'école est un à mon avis un très bon
outil pour ça j'essaie de faire des
efforts peut-être après j'aurais après
ça serait normal pour moi de venir à
l'école tous les jours je serai stable
et après là je pourrais faire un métier
un métier qui m'intéresse tu crois
vraiment qu'il y a un lien ou tu dis ça
parce que bon tu penses que c'est ce
qu'il faut dire non je pense que il y a
un lien parce que si on a
vaut mieux au moins aller à l'école et
avoir un diplôme et faire un petit
métier parce que trouver un métier sans
diplôme je crois que je crois que c'est
pas facile
je comprends
c'est bien
pourquoi 14 ans quand même
parce que alors là je pense parce que je
vois des réussites parce que moi j'ai la
chance à faire 14 ans que je suis là
quand je vois des anciens élèves qui ont
galéré qui ont été en échec scolaire et
j'en ai vu qui revient j'ai pas dit
avant qui reviennent me voir avec leur
bébé qui m'invite à leur mariage ça m'a
porté mon satisfaction de me dire bah
tout compte fait malgré tout malgré tout
ils s'en sont sortis quoi d'une manière
ou d'une autre
s'en sortir d'une manière ou d'une autre
Fabienne l'assistante sociale
d'Aubervilliers aimerait y croire elle
aussi
mais elle a pose café elle a surtout
envie d'oublier un peu son stress avec
sa collègue Mélanie qui est aussi sa
meilleure amie
mais le boulot va les rattraper un homme
est à l'accueil il n'a pas d'endroit où
dormir ce soir
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le métier
une rupture d'hébergement la hantise de
Fabienne
pour cette nuit donc
on va aller voir ce qu'il en est
et vous seriez pourquoi
juste que j'aime pas
du tout pourquoi j'aime pas du tout ça
parce que les très souvent on est sans
solution à la fin de l'entretien après
avoir évalué et donc les gens repartent
et sont toujours là c'est vraiment une
grosse source d'angoisse pour moi c'est
et en plus personne seul est encore
moins de choses que pour les familles
l'homme à l'accueil à 32 ans cela fait
trois mois qu'il ne sait pas où dormir
il est en train de divorcer n'a pas de
travail pas de quoi payer un loyer
Fabienne était de Mélanie va tenter de
trouver une solution pour ce soir il est
14h30
ou n'importe où mais là c'est pas
possible
le 115 le numéro d'hébergement d'urgence
mise en place par les pouvoirs publics
pas tout à fait au point
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des fois on fait ça 100 fois sur les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas le 115
ils ont
quasiment
ils ont 1800 appels par jour trois
écoutants ils peuvent pas prendre 1800
Athènes par jour donc voilà ça répond
pas ça s'en occuper les initatures et
et c'est tout bien qu'assistante sociale
Fabienne n'a pas d'accès privilégié au
115 elle va maintenant appeler les
centres d'hébergement mais ce n'est pas
beaucoup mieux
Fabienne et Mélanie vont donner des
coups de fil partout pendant deux heures
sans succès pour ce soir ou même pour
cette semaine aucune place n'est
disponible nulle part
pas même au 115 que Fabienne a fini par
joindre très bien je vous remercie au
revoir non c'était le 115
c'est pas possible
ou pas je pense qu'ils ont fait toujours
possible on en a pas rappelé les gens
prenez une liste de numéros de téléphone
et puis les faire un pardon tout ce
qu'il y a à faire je pense
comme Fabienne le craignait l'homme
repart sans solution
ce soir il dormira dans sa voiture
pour Fabienne un échec difficile à
supporter
c'est quand même dingue moi je vais
rentrer chez moi tranquille et bah lui
il va dormir dans sa voiture où il va
devoir aller demander à quelqu'un de
l'héberger encore une fois c'est c'est
d'une grande violence pour nous mon
imagine bien que c'est encore plus
violent pour les personnes mais c'est
insupportable de pas trouver de solution
pour ça parce que c'est quand même assez
essentiel dormir dans la rue c'est pas
possible et pourtant si
mon père mail au collège Jean Jaurès
l'heure n'est pas au découragement
l'assistante sociale Laurence Ribaucourt
est en colère
la comptable de l'éducation nationale en
charge du collège a envoyé des menaces
de saisie d'huissier à une douzaine de
familles qui avait des dettes de cantine
Laurence n'a pas été consultée elle veut
s'expliquer avec le principal
la secrétaire du service comptabilité
participe à la Réunion
[Musique]
le parcours administratif c'est-à-dire
avant que ça aille à l'huissier de toute
façon ça passe partout enfin je veux
dire on peut bloquer quoi avant que ça
parte des yeux qui sont partis pour les
huissiers
par exemple écoute nous on a plus
d'argent l'agent comptable elle exige
que l'on que l'on fasse partie à les
choses la cantine coûte aux parents 120
euros par trimestre jusqu'à présent
certains ne pouvaient la payer que grâce
au fond social du collège financé par
l'État mais ce Fond Social a été réduit
de 40% l'an dernier les trois quarts
c'est quand même des situations de fond
social là
de l'année dernière c'est sur une
situation comme eux avec les trois
frères et sœurs c'est une famille qui a
toujours fait du fond social qui a
toujours fait ses dossiers en temps et
en heure qui a fait ses dossiers de
bourse etc et ça c'est quoi c'est le
fait de l'année dernière qu'on avait
plus de fond social et au premier
trimestre les gammes continuent à manger
il y a plus de fonds sociales donc ils
ont à payer le plein pot donc ils vont
être directement en fait victime du fait
qu'on n'est pas eu de foncer ça sur le
troisième trimestre l'année dernière le
premier tu suis ici on a eu du Fond
Social il serait pas là quoi voilà ça
c'est la famille qui a été expulsée on a
discuté en début d'année il y a une
expulsion de la famille
il faut que tu me donnes les noms des
familles qui sont réelles difficultés et
moi je vais demander à l'agent comptable
si on peut sachant que ça va être pour
nous en lui expliquant les cas que tu
m'auras expliquer dans le détail
donc de demander à l'huissier qu'il ne
qu'il interrompre la poursuite on dit
voilà c'est tout mais nous on dit obligé
de marquer le coup
on aurait pu discuter avant je suis
d'accord
bien merci beaucoup Laurence a obtenu le
vrai examen de 4K sur 12 mais le
problème demeure depuis la baisse de
l'aide de l'État plus de la moitié des
demi pensionnaires du collège ont dû
quitter la cantine on en est tous à
subir quoi y compris les fonctionnaires
voilà pour le coup on subit on subit les
baisses de on subit les changements de
décision subit les saisons politiques
tout le temps tout le temps et dans ces
quartiers là c'est un des quartiers où
la pauvreté grandit ou les gens galèrent
de plus en plus au quotidien les choix
actuels c'est de les laisser un peu pour
compte de les abandonner il se le
ressentent comme ça les habitants nous
aussi et on en donne moins pour ceux qui
ont moins
heureusement pour elle il y a aussi des
moments sympas au collège comme cette
séance d'essayage avant la classe de
neige
les enfants n'ont pas de combinaison de
ski Laurence s'est débrouillé pour les
avoir gratuitement
les vêtements c'est des profs du
personnel du collège qu'on donnait et
puis on a aussi le club des prévention à
rimage l'explicateur de rue avec
lesquels on travaille beaucoup qui nous
ont passé quelques vêtements puis nous
on leur passe après les nôtres les
échanges entre les associations
ce voyage pourrait paraître anecdotique
mais pour Laurence il a au contraire une
grande influence sur la scolarité des
enfants
la maman repart avec une solution
Laurence lui a proposé une aide du
collège 170 euros sur 240 à chaque
classe de neige la moitié des familles
sont aidées mais cette année a été plus
difficile que les autres faute de
subventions le collège a dû puiser dans
le budget de l'éducation physique
Laurence n'est pas au bout de ses peines
quatre jours avant le départ elle est
convoquée d'urgence chez le principal
la comptable de l'éducation nationale
s'est déplacée elle menace d'annuler le
séjour car certaines familles n'ont pas
encore payé leur part
nous ne sommes pas autorisés à filmer la
réunion
ou les élèves partent
pas me retrouver après avec des élèves
qui sont partis une facture du
fournisseur et pas de check oui mais bon
vous savez la vie allez les voir vous
comprendrez entre la vie et puis ce qui
est la théorie la pratique voilà quoi
j'ai une responsabilité personnelle et
pécuniaire si je paye alors que je n'ai
pas de crédits
c'est moi qui paye personnellement alors
moi je veux bien entendre beaucoup de
choses mais je ne peux pas payer
personnellement pour les élèves du lycée
du collège Jean Jaurès moi je veux que
tout soit boucler sur mon bureau avant
le départ bien sûr
[Musique]
alors et bien on s'est retrouvé face à
la problématique comptable
d'établissement tous les établissements
scolaires c'est à dire qu'il y a la
comptabilité et puis il y a la réalité
la pratique après la réunion la
comptable défend son ultimatum
comment ça s'est passé alors cette
réunion oui parce que la logique d'une
comptable c'est pas forcément la même
que celle d'une assistante sociale
scolaire ah non moi j'ai une logique
comptable
non en l'occurrence on arrive à les
régler
en ce moment pour être plus dur avec mes
collègues ou pas absolument pas un grand
nombre parce que on applique la loi de
comptable c'est tout
la loi de comptable mais Laurence sous
pression elle fait le tour des classes
pour relancer les élèves et leurs
parents très important on ne partira pas
sans l'échec d'accord
n'oubliez pas de ramener les chèques
Laurence et les élèves réussiront-ils à
partir il lui reste 48 heures pour
récupérer tous les chèques
les obstacles c'est presque une
motivation supplémentaire pour Benoît
Candon l'avocat marseillais
quand certaines institutions lui
résistent ils n'hésitent pas à
s'attaquer à elle frontalement
témoin l'histoire qui est arrivé à
Monsieur Madame rit ce père de quatre
enfants sans aucune ressource n'arrivait
pas à nourrir sa famille il y a six mois
il a demandé au Conseil général une aide
sociale à l'enfance mais à essuyer un
refus alors motif à ce jour je ne suis
pas en mesure de donner une suite
favorable à votre demande en l'absence
d'éléments permettant d'évaluer votre
situation budgétaire réelle ils n'y font
pas confiance ils se disent qu'en fait
il est il est plein de fric alors il est
pas en place et en fait il vient de
demander de l'argent bon
Benoît Candon a alors poursuivi le
Conseil général devant le tribunal
administratif avec un argument jusqu'à
leur inédit une nouvelle interprétation
du code de l'action sociale
lorsque la santé la sécurité l'entretien
ou l'éducation d'un enfant l'exige et
que la famine n'a pas les ressources
suffisantes et bien le président du
conseil général accorde une aide
financière qui généralement est mensuel
le texte dit le président du conseil
général accorde une aide financière et
il y a toujours une différence dans la
loi que entre le terme entre le présent
et puis le une potentialité par exemple
le président du conseil général peut
accorder une aide c'est pas pareil que
accorde là il accorde il doit accorder
des arguments qui ont su convaincre les
juges maître-candon a obtenu pour
Monsieur Mamery une première aide de 320
euros au courant
des grosses institutions comme ça
c'est assez amusant parce que
parce que souvent elles font mal leur
travail et jamais personne n'est allé
mettre l'emmener dans ce type de
problème son nez pardon donc en général
ça c'est couronné de succès
à dire que on se rend compte qu'il y a
des pratiques administratives qui sont
complètement délirantes Benoît Candon
aime visiblement la bagarre il reçoit
maintenant madame boussettou son
propriétaire la poursuit pour des loyers
impayés que mettre quand on va contester
mais pour l'avocat la ferme ne doit pas
s'arrêter là il veut à son tour attaquer
le propriétaire pour l'insalubrité de
son logement on profite de la première
procédure où on est où elle doit
comparaître devant le juge pour
s'expliquer sur les loyers elle va
demander dans la même audience au
propriétaire de s'expliquer sur
l'insalubrité et ensuite en passant par
un expertise elle aura la preuve elle
pourra revenir devant le juge avec la
preuve que le propriétaire c'est
vraiment pas du tout à quitter de ces
obligations d'entretien de du logement
et donc demander des des dommages
intérêts en contrepartie
voilà où habite la famille de Madame
boussettou un quartier qui sera bientôt
démoli
même le canapé il va pas le principal
problème ici c'est l'eau l'humidité qui
remonte du sol
je vais toucher
l'autre fois il y a du champignon qui a
poussé ici bon moi j'ai dit champignons
parce que je suis pas spécialiste il a
dit moi le champignon je le mange
si vous voulez bien
là de la dame en haut si bon aux
toilettes là vous allez vous voyez pas
dans le tuyau là vous voyez pas un peu
de truc marrant là
mais comme c'est un peu ouvert là il y a
des gouttes qui qui tombent j'étais en
train de préparer et
j'entends ces je regarde et je vois là
les gouttes qui tombent de j'ai arrêté
de préparer j'avais même pas envie de
manger j'ai pris le petit et je suis
sortie regardez les prises électriques
malgré l'insalubrité des lieux le loyer
s'élève à 400 euros selon les locataires
le propriétaire n'a jamais fait les
travaux qui s'imposaient pour l'avocat
il est hors la loi
l'audience a lieu cet après-midi au
tribunal d'instance de Marseille Benoît
Candon s'apprête à plaider pour Madame
boussessou le propriétaire s'est déplacé
c'est un ancien marchand de biens qui
possède de nombreux appartements à
Marseille très à l'aise il tient
ouvertement des propos racistes
c'est une clientèle un peu spéciale
j'ai des immeubles où il y a des
Français
c'est ça c'est ça que la décision enfin
si c'est il y a vraiment une justice et
ben ça va être bien rendu
est-ce que c'est d'après vous des
conditions des centres pour nous non non
[Musique]
et les conditions qui sont pas descentes
elles sont qui est responsable de ça qui
responsable le sol c'est tout bon
on a mis une pompe qui évacue au
continuellement c'est pas celui que ça
sorte toujours
il y a un problème d'humidité donc c'est
vous qui êtes responsable juridiquement
non il faut quitter l'appartement c'est
tout vous reconnaissez qu'on peut pas
vivre dedans
à la sortie de l'audience maître cordon
semble optimiste
on en a pris une bonne c'est que il est
poursuivi par le tribunal de police
aussi pour les infractions
réglementaires d'hygiène qu'il a
commisent ce qu'il a été rappelé à Lord
depuis au moins non par les services
d'hygiène et il a rien fait bon moi
j'explique parce que
sont toujours dans l'attente du jugement
retour dans le Pas-de-Calais alliévin
Stéphane Coquerel le banquier qui veut
changer la vie des pauvres a parfois des
déconvenues c'est ici que l'association
pour laquelle il travaille l'a dit
finance les créations d'entreprises de
ceux à qui toutes les portes se sont
fermées
contrairement à l'avocat marseillais et
aux assistantes sociales Stéphane
Coquerel se sent proches des valeurs
libérales
plutôt que d'affronter le système il
préfère croire aux vertus de
l'initiative individuelle
la lutte contre la pauvreté elle est
dans l'initiative c'est à dire que je
crois réellement que la création de son
propre emploi le microcrédit donc ce
qu'on applique au quotidien c'est une
façon justement de de se remettre en
route et de de trouver un moyen de s'en
sortir de par soi-même c'est-à-dire en
devenant son propre patron en se mettant
à son compte et en dépendant plus d'un
employeur et ça c'est très libéral c'est
à l'opposé de la système à quoi
s'en sortir par soi-même une belle idée
mais pas toujours simple à mettre en
pratique tout ce qui vous arrive encore
bah non rien voilà voilà
alors c'est passé comme ça vous avez un
souci là ce matin non j'ai pas de souci
tu fais toujours les mêmes tous les
jours quoi voilà pourquoi votre souci ce
matin
parce que voilà j'ai reçu le les
mouvements les mouvements des billes à
la case départ
et que en fait donc je vois
c'est une page par créateur
et donc je vois un ensemble de un
ensemble de projets qu'on a financé qui
qui ont des mouvements de trésorerie
négatifs et
et voilà ces problématique parce que
parce que c'est des chèques sans
provision s'ils sont pas couverts ils
vont être rejetés s'ils sont rejetés sa
vengerait des frais si ça vengeant des
frais ça va diminuer à trésorerie qui va
donc faire encore moins de trésorerie
donc moins de provision ce qui fait que
ce sera des mouvements enfin c'est une
mauvaise spirale quoi voilà donc voilà
ça a l'air de vous mettre en colère
ça n'est pas en colère ça me
[Applaudissements]
c'est là c'est on est vraiment dans les
parties de de d'assistanat là c'est à
dire que là il faut aller les gens
savent qu'il faut pas faire de chèque
sans provision et ils font des chèques
sans provision et donc il faut les
prendre par la main et dire c'est pas
bien par exemple vous voyez la
découverte de plus de 20 000 francs
c'est son prélèvement addict qui passe
pas et on le trouve plus voilà
c'est pour votre pomme là clairement
ben non mais c'est à dire que il va
falloir le le secouer quoi parce que
voilà si jamais vous n'arrivez pas à
récupérer cet argent on va vous taper
sur les doigts
on mesure aussi mon taux d'impayés et si
mon taux d'impayé augmente
bah c'est c'est forcément des reproches
qu'on va me faire tant que mon supérieur
hiérarchique me fera de
d'un manque d'efficacité voilà
des fois vous vous dites que les
banquiers ils ont peut-être raison de
refuser alors les banquiers
traditionnelles des fois je me dis que
je comprends pourquoi les banquiers vont
pas sur ces projets là voilà
et je comprends aussi pourquoi nous on y
va parce que si on y allait pas nous on
apporterait pas de solution à ces
gens-là
[Applaudissements]
un entrepreneur parti sans laisser
d'adresses des problèmes de trésorerie
pour d'autres Stéphane Coquerel est
parfois découragé
mais il a aussi des satisfactions la
livraison aujourd'hui d'une baraque à
frites et les Pilogue d'un long combat
chez Valou et Choupette c'est la
friterie de Valérie GRISLIN et de sa
mère
elles doivent toutes les deux une pierre
chandelle à Stéphane Coquerel
une création d'entreprise
grâce à la digue et qui me suivent et
bon j'ai travaillé pendant un an et on
m'a mis le feu à ma friterie
ou je sais pas exactement
j'étais assurée d'une paire
d'exploitation et je pensais avoir
l'assurance de friterie dedans mais
j'avais pas d'assurance dedans
vous ressentez quoi là
heureuse j'ai du mal à vraiment à réagir
encore pour l'instant je me demande si
je suis dans un rêve la réalité
Stéphane Coquerel leur a reprêté 5000
euros c'est le premier versement pour
l'achat de la nouvelle baraque à frites
combien d'heures par semaine alors
pour nous c'est 10h 11h minuit ça dépend
en tant que client est là on sait et
vous commencez à quelle heure le matin
on arrive ici moi j'arrive pour 7h elle
elle arrive pour 6h on a vu qu'elle
était qu'elle avait une capacité de
travail dingue qu'elle était capable de
rembourser quand il a fallu réintervenir
la banque voulant toujours pas y aller
parce que le fait que il y a eu le
problème d'assurance etc qui fait qu'il
y a un ensemble d'éléments qui font que
elle était toujours pas financée par la
Banque en direct on met on a pu remonter
l'intervention sans aucun problème parce
que on avait en plus
l'assurance que c'est un emplacement qui
marche quoi
chez Valérie griselin l'ancienne
friterie est toujours là totalement
carbonisée
très bien nettoyer à l'écrit triste
loulou
Stéphane a vraiment changé sa vie
auparavant Valérie vivait grâce au RMI
depuis son quotidien c'est beaucoup
amélioré avant une chose que je pouvais
pas me permettre c'est d'aller acheter
un steak ou un truc comme ça dans le
temps je pouvais pas me permettre que
maintenant je le peux je regarde pas les
machines installés ou alors on m'a
acheté un fromage qui me plaît ou
quelque chose qui me plaît quoi
je m'en sens beaucoup mieux et puis bon
je me sens mieux dans ma peau parce que
je sais que j'ai quelque chose derrière
que je travaille quoi je sais que je
suis pas tout le temps à tourner en rond
ou à traîner à droite à gauche ou j'ai
mon boulot derrière qui m'attend
2 février dernier c'est le 59 de l'appel
de l'abbé Pierre en faveur descend
logique Fabienne est dans la rue avec
plusieurs centaines d'assistantes
sociales de la région parisienne
elles veulent faire pression sur le
gouvernement pour qu'il construise 300
000 logements sociaux de plus en
Île-de-France
qui sont concernées directement par le
problème quand on est dans une situation
très précaire c'est peut-être beaucoup
plus difficile de se mobiliser alors que
nous nous avons cette possibilité on a
le recul nous pour le faire quand on est
dans une bataille au quotidien pour sa
survie on a peut-être pas là-dedans quoi
la manifestation se termine place de la
Sorbonne
dans son travail Fabienne se sent de
moins en moins utile c'est la société
dans son ensemble qu'elle voudrait
changer pour elle cette mobilisation
n'est qu'un début
de toute façon
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard elle organise
un dîner chez elle avec quelques
collègues d'Aubervilliers le matin même
elle aura annoncé qu'elle quittait son
travail
moi je ferai pas de discours je te le
dis tout de suite
[Musique]
Fabienne va rester assistante sociale as
comme on dit dans le métier mais dans
une entreprise privée un travail plus
confortable il y a un épuisement quand
même par rapport en tout cas il faut que
tu partes je suis en danger
je suis en danger et je suis en train de
j'ai peur de devenir une asse que je
veux pas devenir
la vieillesse est grille évidemment
indifférente blindés justement plus
humaine qui n'entend plus et
qui répond à côté quoi
pour se protéger parce qu'on ne peut
plus rien faire
Stéphane Coquerel lui pense qu'il peut
encore faire quelque chose
ce matin il va tenter de convaincre le
comité de crédit de l'ADI de prêter 4000
euros pour l'entreprise SOS soudure de
Monsieur Belhassen mais il a d'abord
d'autres dossiers à présenter autour de
la table des bénévoles de l'association
Stéphane a parfois du mal à les
convaincre de sortir l'argent pour
répondre comme avec ce premier projet
une société de pose de portail
[Musique]
stéphane est un peu inquiet il doit
maintenant défendre SOS soudure et porte
sur ses épaules l'avenir de Monsieur
bellasset
il a une volonté une détermination qui
font que rien ne l'arrête aujourd'hui il
a il a il a trouvé son marché il a son
savoir-faire l'entendre parler de
soudure c'est passionnant moi-même je je
vais chercher des choses à faire lui
faire souder tellement j'ai envie qu'il
de le voir à l'œuvre
alors la stratégiquement commencer par
la personne qui va dire oui
[Rires]
c'est un bon dossier
c'est OK André Hervé
oui oui
j'avais déjà dit oui voilà
Grand Chelem
comme je les aime
grâce à Stéphane monsieur bellahcen RMI
St sera bientôt chef d'entreprise et
voilà bon
dernière rencontre entre les deux hommes
avant le grand saut
comment vous vous sentez
exactement encore plus confirmé quoi
maintenant ça compte ferme bien que
quand on a envie de faire quelque chose
et à mon un autre il y a une réaction ça
montre aussi que des gens croient en Moi
statistiquement monsieur il a combien de
chance dans 5 ans d'avoir toujours son
entreprise statistiquement un peu moins
d'une chance sur deux humainement 100%
de chance d'être encore là dans 5 ans il
va il va tout casser
né un redémarrage et ce dont je suis
fier c'est de toutes les personnes que
j'ai inséré en fait
[Musique]
dimanche 1er février Laurence peut-être
fier elle aussi devant le collège Jean
Jaurès à Montfermeil c'est le grand
départ
ça n'a pas été facile mais son
obstination à payer alors vous avez tous
les chèques non mais on a une grande
partie tous les familles ont participé
en tout cas voilà et on a des du reste
de l'argent qui restera rentrera après
vous l'avez vu hier vendredi matin donc
on a fait le point et en fait à la liste
simplement que tout le monde est donné
une participation monsieur mon tout le
monde a donné une participation elle a
des attestations comme quoi hépéro après
parce que si voilà on a une majorité
quand même
je suis à la télé
tous ces gamins ce qu'on a quand même
classe dont les trois quarts des gamins
sont cité qui partent à 100% et ça c'est
une belle victoire
[Musique]
Benoît Candon l'avocat marseillais et
lui reparti dans d'autres combats les
locataires de cet HLM ont fait appel à
lui pour être relogé ce qui va pas du
tout OK
[Musique]
j'estime qu'on est un peu en position de
force c'est que on a la loi pour nous
pour une fois enfin totalement pour nous
c'est à dire que la loi dit c'est
reparti pour un tour après 7 ans de
plaidoirie Benoît Candon n'a pas
l'intention de lâcher de sitôt son
combat pour les pauvres
[Musique]